j'ouvre notre second débat consacré au
au lien on on l'évoquait de l'Iran avec
le Hamas son rôle au Proche Orient
comment le régime des Mola finance-t-il
de nombreuses milices dans les pays qui
entourent Israël pourquoi se
rapproche-t-il de la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine les révoltes provoqué par la
mort de Mascha Amini c'était en
septembre 2022 est-ce qu'elles peuvent
redémarrer après le décès d'une lcéenne
de 16 ans qui refusait de porter le
voile islamique et qui a été agressé
dans le métro avant de répondre à ces
questions on voit comment euh les
dirigeants iraniens réagissent depuis
l'attaque terroriste du 7 octobre Jérôme
Rabier c'est une stratégie de longue
date de l'Iran une véritable doctrine
refuser l'existence même d'Israël mais
en évitant soigneusement un affrontement
direct alors l'Iran finance des alliés
état ou milices politiqu souvent doté
d'une branche armée ainsi il est le
principal soutien du Hezbollah au Liban
du régime de Bachar al-Assad en Syrie du
ass bien sûr dans la bande de Gaza mais
aussi des rebelles outis au Yémen qui
tiennent une partie du pays dont la
capitale Sanaa ces satellites de l'Iran
sont chargés d'harceler aussi bien
Israël que son principal allié américain
sans que l'Iran soit officiellement
impliqué mais toujours en évitant de
rentrer dans un conflit direct avec
Israël parce que les dirigeants iraniens
c'est un peu ce qui fait leur force
c'est un mélange d'idéologie de
pragmatisme ils ont bien compris que un
conflit direct avec Israël ils ont ce
sera un conflit avec les États-Unis et
ils ont tout ils ne veulent pas ils ont
tout à perdre de ce type de conflit le
régime iranien promet ainsi des réplique
si Israël frappe trop fortement sur Gaza
mais peu de chance qu'il aille au-delà
des roquettes envoyées sur Israël depuis
le sud Liban par ses alliés du hzbollah
derrière l'affrontement indirect avec
Israël c'est bien l'ennemi juré les
États-Unis qui sont visés par le régime
iranien l'ayatol rameney les désignant
même comme les responsables de la sur
Gaza l'Amérique est définitivement
complice des criminels c'est-à-dire de
ce crime les mains de l'Amérique sont
souillées par le sang des opprimés en
fait les États-Unis dirigent d'une
certaine manière le crime qui est en
train d'être commis à Gaza en finançant
tous ces satellites l'Iran s'impose
aussi comme un interlocuteur
indispensable pour tous les pays de la
région au moment où l'Arabie Saoudite et
d'autres pouvaient être tentés de
normaliser les relations avec Israël
c'est important pour eux que à travers
ce conflit on quelque part on a l'air de
redécouvrir le le rôle central
quasi essentiel que que jeouirant dans
la région et je pense que ça c'est c'est
presque le l'axe principal de leur
politique régionale de quasiment depuis
la fin de la guerre avec l'IRAC au début
des années 90 cette guerre indirecte
uniquement par force interposée protège
ainsi pour l'instant l'Iran de
représaill direct d'Israël ou de ses
alliés le rôle de l'Iran les craintes
d'un embrasement régional on en débat
avec Cham maaremi bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes anthropologue chercheur au CNRS
spécialiste de l'Iran et vous publié
femme vie liberté aux éditions La
Découverte Bernard Ourcade bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes géographe spécialis
de l'Iran directeur de recherche et
mérite au CNRS et vous avez dirigé la
revue documentation photographique Iran
paradoxe d'une nation paru justement aux
édition du CNRS Asni Abidi bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes politologue
directeur du Centre d'études et de
recherche sur le mond Arab et
méditerranéen et puis vous avez dirigé
cet ouvrage collectif le Moyen-Orient
selon Joe Biden paru aux éditions Éric
Bonier j'accueille également en duplexe
Delphine Minoui grand reporteur au
Figaro correspondante pour le
Moyen-Orient basé à Istanbul bonsoir
bienvenue à vous et vous publiez je vous
écris de Teran euh aux éditions poche de
du seuil au point euh Mathieu
croissandau évidemment est resté à mes
côtés première question Cham maaremi
comment les les Iraniens les Iraniennes
qui sont mobilisé depuis plus d'un an
contre contre le régime des Mola comment
ils réagissent aujourd'hui au conflit
est-ce qu'il y a une solidarité qui
s'exprime avec le peuple palestinien
qu'est-ce qui se passe ben c'est c'est
c'est très compliqué parce que il y a
pas d'unité en faitou euh il y a euh à
la fois des gens qui réagissent selon
des lignes de partage géostratégiques
l'ennemi de mon ennemi et mon ami donc
qui accepte en fait le discours le le
narratif de la guerre euh mais quand
même il y a il y a aussi beaucoup de
gens qui euh d'une part n'accepte pas ce
discours de la guerre donc en fait ne se
situe pas derrière des États qui sont
opposés à d'autres États et des forces
qui sont opposés à d'autres forces
mais sont sont extrêmement focalisés sur
leur leur travail d'opposition à la
République islamique et puis il y a
aussi une partie de de toute façon de
l'opinion publique iranienne qui mais
historiquement depuis bon plusieurs
années voir décennies n'est pas du tout
dupe du discours TR palestinien de la
République islamique et en fait voit ce
discours là comme une une espèce de de
une partie en fait de l'hégémonie
iranienne ou de l'impérialisme iranien
dans dans la région oui alors je ve bien
vous entendre là-dessus Bernard
justement sur ce cette cause
palestinienne qu'est-ce qu'elle
représente pour le pouvoir en place en
Iran aujourd'hui on dit que l'ayat
romini avait dit à Arafat il n'y a pas
de cause palestinienne il n'y a qu'une
cause islamique h pour bien dire mon but
c'est la libération de Jérusalem les
palestinens on voudrait également le
faire don on pourrait s'entendre sur
certain nombre de sujets mais mon
objectif n'est pas forcément libération
de la Palestine et il faut bien voir que
à l'époque de la Révolution islamique
pour la première fois l'Iran du chat
avait l'Iran après le chat avait une
ambition régionale dans le monde
musulman l'Iran chiite et persan pouvait
difficilement être reconnu comme un
leader dans le monde arabe et sunnit ils
ont donc pris un passeport Isra
palestinien la Palestine était pour eux
un moyen d'être reconnu dans la rue
arabe disant je vais défendre la
Palestine vous arabes et sunit pendant
40 ans n'avez rien fait vous allez voir
moi je vais faire quelque chose espérant
par ce biais là réunir effectivement les
gens proalestiniens la cause
palestinienne qui dans les années 80
était une rassemblé beaucoup de monde ça
marche ça a marché ça n'a pas beaucoup
marché parce que la guerre irakiran est
arrivée tout de suite et très rapidement
ce qui comptait pour l'Iran c'était à
défendre du territoire national une
guerre nationale et non plus une guerre
extérieure il faut bien voir que
jusqu'en 1982 les attentats commis en
France par exemple ou ailleurs était
fait par les Palestiniens les Iraniens
n'avaient pas les moyens de tuer à
l'étranger à partir de 82 les
Palestiniens ont été obligés de quitter
le Liban et donc il y a plus de
palestiniens au Liban disponible le
Hamas le fata le jjihad islamique
quitter Terran tir et Liban est partir
en Tunisie et à ce moment-là les
Iraniens ont créé le Hesbollah parti
chiite locale qui a toujours existé
qu'ils ont renforcé et donc désormais
pour le Hezbollah le problème n'est pas
la Palestine ce sont des des it libanais
qui sont au Liban leur ambition est
d'être au Liban de s'installer d'avoir
le pouvoir au Liban de faire pression
sur Israël aussi donc ils peuvent
s'entendre les Palestiniens un certain
nombre de dossiers mais fondamentalement
leur objectif n'est pas la Palestine ou
alors évidemment le hzbollah on y
parlera on en parlera pardon un peu plus
en longueur dans ce débat à quel point
les les les attaques terroristes du
Hamas servent les intérêts iraniens
aujourd'hui notamment est-ce qu'on peut
dire que l'Iran est un peu moins
marginalisé qu'auparavant oui il est
moins marginalisé parce que que les
liens avec le Hamas fait partie de cette
police d'assurance que recherche le
régime iranien depuis la guerre avec les
avec l'IRAC c'est-à-dire que les
iraniens avaient compris que la
meilleure défense c'est déplacer les
frontières ne pas attendre l'ennemi
jusqu'à qu'il arrive en Iran certes il y
a le programme des missiles balistiques
et autres mais aussi le programme
nucléaire puisque les Iraniens espèrent
en tout cas arriver à ce seuil nucléaire
mais surtout doter la région de de
certains agents d'entrepreneurs certains
appelle proxy mais je pense beaucoup
plus que ça finalement déplacer le
conflit déplacer la guerre au-delà des
frontières iraniennes narger les
Américains en Irak ils ont réussi aussi
en Syrie ils ont réussi avec plusieurs
mouvements qui sont proches donc c'est
multiplié les mou véritable mosï une
véritable véritable mosaïque ce n'est
plus quelque chose de pyramidal c'est
vraiment à horizontal où les Iraniens
peuvent avoir d'abord une grande
flexibilité ses acteurs quand ils
veulent et toujours en apparaître
finalement comme un état qui n'est pas
lié d'une manière j'allais dire presque
né dogmatique ni organique avec ces
mouvements et ça c'est la force de
régime mais alors ce ce que j'entends ce
que vous n dit je reste avec vous c'est
que c'est plus avisé interne qu' visisé
hégémonique territorial c'est ça c'est
plus un réflexe de protection pour les
de pour régimen c'est les deux c'est
vrai que c'est d'abord l'intérieur
c'està-dire que les Iraniens ont besoin
d'une certaine stabilité à l'intérieur
vous avez remarqué que tout de suite
américain israélien disaiit que non non
non on n pas de preuve de l'implication
des Iraniens dans l'attaque du C octobre
l'attaque horrible du 7 octobre et
pourtant on sait qu'il y a un soutien
militaire il y a des conseils militaires
qui se font il y a des rencontres en
quelque sorte les Iraniens ont besoin de
cette cette stabilité de cette sécurité
d'être loin des radars tout en ayant
bien sûr un contrôle pas forcément un
contrôle direct parce qu' attention
chaque mouvement a sa marche de manœuvre
et c'est ça à mon avis le élément qui
éta positif évidemment Delphine Minoui
je je me tourne vers vous parce que on n
pas encore parlé des accords d'Abraham
qui euh qui voyait Israël se rapproché
de plusieurs pays arabes depuis
2020 ça ça représentait quel risque pour
l'Iran et et quelle part ça prend dans
l'explication de de cette guerre qui
dure depuis 24 jours maintenant
oui vous savez une des doctrines
assumées de la République islamique
c'est de dire cette idée de vaincre sans
tirer une seule cartouche et de se tenir
éloigné en effet des des conflits et
notamment de de la question israélienne
et je pense qu'à l'heure actuelle la
République islamique d'Iran tire
pleinement conflit pleinement profit de
cette guerre notamment parce que
justement comme vous le mentionnez elle
permet de de torpiller ces accords
d'Abraham qui consistaient à lancer un
un processus de normalisation avec entre
Israël les les émirat Arab Unis Bahrain
le Maroc par extension aussi l'Arabie
Saoudite et aussi la Turquie et euh dans
un deuxème temps aussi cette cette crise
ce conflit euh permet à l'Iran de de
renforcer ce fameux axe du mal qui
s'était déjà consolidé pendant le
conflit entre le Hezbollah libanais et
Israël en en 2006 cet axe du mal cet axe
de la résistance qui qui euh qui
contient à la fois l'Iran qui contient
la Syrie le Hamas le Djihad islamique le
Hezbollah libanais et puis j'ai j'ai
l'impression aussi dans un 3oème temps
cette cette guerre permet aussi
indirectement à l'Iran de d'aller entre
guillemets harceler euh par
l'intermédiaire de ces proxis les
Américains on l'a vu avec les les
attaques récentes de certains soldats
américains notamment en Irak donc des
attaques apparemment menées par des par
des milices irakiennes et puis le 4ème
point euh et qui rejoint plus des
affaires de considération interne en
Iran euh cette crise elle permet tout
simplement à la République islamique de
de faire diversion sur la révolte
interne qui couve en Iran depuis depuis
un an depuis la mort de la jeune Massa
Amini pour un voile mal porté ouis et on
y reviendra évidemment sur ce cet aspect
intérieur qui est très important on a
commencé à l'aborder l'une des questions
qui qui est crucial depuis le 7 octobre
c'est la responsabilité directe ou non
de de l'Iran dans la préparation des des
attaques du du ramas on écoute sur ce
thème le Premier ministre israélien
[Musique]
netaniaahou l'Iran soutient le le Hamas
je pense que 90 % du budget militaire du
Hamas provient de l'Iran il finance il
organise il dirige mais je ne peux pas
vous dire que dans cette action
spécifique à ce moment précis il faisait
partie de la
microplanification Bernard l'Iran
pouvait-il ne pas être au courant être
au courant oui bien évidemment du timing
non de l'idée peut-être il faut revenir
je crois à l'accord imposé par les
Chinois d'une entente iranarabie
Saoudite oui deux pays pour la première
fois ont décidé d'être un peu réaliste
disant je ne vais jamais conrir l'autre
pays donc faisant une coexistance
pacifique et ils ont envisager avant de
de rétablir diplomatique de résoudre les
problèmes problèmes yéménites problème
de l'Irak problème du Liban problème
d'Israël et cetera tout ont été mis sur
la table finalement les chinois sont
arrivés en disant arrêteant en tout ça
vous rétablissez des relations
diplomatiques le reste sera résolu après
coup l'Iran a donc mis le problème
palestinien parmi les dossiers qui
fâchent et qu'il fallait résoudre et
imposer au saoudiens en disant voilà ces
questionsl il faut qu'on les résolve un
jour ou l'autre ils ont donc préparé les
Iraniens une action diplomatique
imposant au saoudiens d'investir dans le
problème palestinien l'Arabie Saoudite
se moque de la Palestine depuis 40 ans
mais Don les rabies vu sans statut
juridique de protecteur des lieux saints
beaucoup d'argent c'est le seul pays de
la région étant un peu extérieur à
pouvoir vraiment peut-être faire quelque
chose mais l'Iran n'est pas fou et
l'Iran une tradition militaire et a dit
combi de vous le signaler de deux fusils
importants le Hamas et le hzbollah quis
ont pour des raisons différentes de
fusil à un coup mais qui qui enerque
Israël et donc il était prévu peut-être
et j'imagine ce scénario que je ne
connais pas jeétais pas mais on peut
imaginer que l'Iran n'était pas contre
le fait que le Hamas par exemple est une
opération militaire spectaculaire pour
dire le problème palestinien il est sur
la table il faut vraiment le traiter
pour pousser les les Saoudiens à
négocier le problème c'est que c'est
parti peut-être de façon incontrôlée
mais aujourd'hui les Iraniens tiennent à
garder leur deuxème fusil à un coup
leboll et ne veulent pas qu' ce F soit
tiré s'il est tiré c'est fini il emploie
aujourd'hui les moyens militaires et
financiers de réarmer le hbolla comme en
2006 j'aimerais vous entendre l'un et
l'autre je vous redonne la parole juste
après mais j'aimerais vous entendre l'un
et l'autre sur cette note des services
secrets américains ils l'ont partagé
avec plusieurs pays occidentaux alors il
y a il y a pas mal d'éléments dans cette
note mais en ce qui concerne l'Iran ils
sont très très prudents sur un rôle
direct de l'Iran dans les attentats du
du 7 octobre vous l'avez vous avez
commencé à évoquer tout à l'heure mais
euh heureusement
ça les arrange rien avoir trouvé est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça comme ça oui et je
crois que
euh Amir abdolayan qui est le ministre
iranien d'A étrangères était à berou
quelques jours avant le 7 octobre
peut-être pour dire bon on va faire
quelque chose qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
et il n'arrête pas les Iraniens
aujourd'hui encore de dire nos
différents proxis les les les éléments
de la de l'axe de la résistance sont
indépendants ce sont des actcteurs
locaux nous nous avons aider bien
évidemment mais c'est eux qui décident
pour bien se dédoiner et dire je ne suis
pas j'ai pas les mains dans le oui mais
ça arrange aussi les États-Unis et même
Israël d'une certaine façon qui est
également euh Israël prudent sur la
responsabilité directe ou frontale de de
l'Iran je pense que benamin netaniao d
vrai c'est-à-dire quand il dit que les
Iraniens on n'a pas de preuve
d'implication dans l'attentat oui je
pense qu'il n'est pas loin de la de la
vérité mais ça veut pas dire le Hamas le
Hamas obtient exactement entre 130 et
150 millions de dollars par année comme
budget comme d'autres États qui qui
financent bien sûr le le le Hamas ça
c'est l'argent que l'Iran verse au Hamas
et il faut mentionner une chose c'est
que en fait les le Hamas a trouvé un
acteur important qui est l'Iran qui
n'est pas très exigeant il n'a pas
beaucoup de conditions le Hamas le dit
lu les Iraniens n'ont pas beaucoup de
conditions n'ont pas beaucoup n'ont pas
un agenda à caché tout ce qu'ils veulent
c'est qu'on soit là comme le champion de
la résistance palestinienne ça les
arrange finalement dans la région mieux
que d'autres États ils disent nous
sommes prêts à aller auprès des pays
arabes notamment le pays du Golf si
parce qu'ils se plaignent pourquoi le
Hamas va chez l'Iranien va chez l'ennemi
éternel chite et et puisque les Iraniens
ont agendat ils disent alors donnez-nous
ce que les Iraniens nous donnent de
l'argent et et des armes çaarrange les
Américains et les Israéliens parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas aller en titiller
les Iraniens vous rendez compte et je
crois que c'est ça la ligne rouge la
ligne rouge c'est pas le hzbollah la LI
rouge c'est pas les milices les milices
iraakiennes et sy syriennes qui vont
frapper les bases américaines c'est
d'aller vers les Iraniens je pense que
là ils ne veulent surtout pas est-ce que
l'Iran allume un autre front qui sera
divvastate
dans la région euh ch makarimi cette
guerre à quel point elle offre au
gouvernement iranien une chance je sais
pas hein peut-être que ils ne le font
pas mais de ressouder ce pays fracturé
que vous nous décriviez tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'ils sont sur cette stratégie
là aujourd'hui ils l'ont toujours été en
fait donc la la question se pose la
question est ouverte moi je peux pas
répondre c'est un pouvoir qui est très
opaqueou mais mais ils l'ont toujours
été c'est-à-dire que la guerre Iran Irak
a historiquement été le moment qui a
permis de construire la République
islamique après la la révolution de 79
et euh et c'est sur le patriotisme des
Iraniens donc c cette question d'e d'une
guerre bon à l'époque était sur le sol
iranien avec beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de morts et de martyre de de de la
guerre en Iran mais cette espèce de
presque malentendu où les Iraniens se
sont rallés massivement au projet de la
République islamique parce que on était
dans une nation en guerre et et en
danger tandis que comme le rappelait
bernardc le brjet romïiste était celui
de Luma des chiites et pas vraiment
celui de la nation euh iranienne mais
donc cette espèce de malentendu qui
permet de ressouder euh autour du
patriotisme c'est la dernière chose
qu'il reste à un état qui en fait depuis
2022 visiblement mais à mon avis depuis
au moins 2017 a perdu en fait tout son
tout son appui tout son enracinement
organique au sein de la société c'est un
état qui était stable parce qu'il était
organiquement enraaciné pendant des
décennies et ce n'est absolument plus le
cas mais est-ce que c'est à l'œuvre même
si effectivement on n'est pas c'est un
pouvoir opaque je comprends de mais
est-ce que dans dans des médias
officiels par exemple il y a il y a ce
réflexe patriotique qui là en ce moment
est activé
le il y a deux choses il y a il y a il y
a le discours de la guerre et il y a la
peur parce que euhh par exemple euh
pendant les 10 ans qu'on qu' a duré le
conflit en Syrie tous les soirs aux
informations les Iraniens recevaient des
images en fait des atrocités syriennes
auxqueles participa l'Iran qui à mon
avis euh le le corps des gardiens de la
la de la Révolution euh a euh une une
puissance et une implantation
extrêmement extrêmement grande hein dans
la région c'est pas c'est pas uniquement
des des financements comme ça beaucoup
de transfer de technologie le le
programme des missiles qui a été donné
au Hezbollah ou au Hamas enfin je dire
on est vraiment dans du dans de la
formation dans de l'entraînement dans de
voilà donc donc en fait ils sont ils
sont quand même un programme et ils ont
une présence extrêmement extrêmement
forte et le message qui était donné au
public iranien c'était si vous bougez il
va vous arrivez ce qui est arrivé en
Syrie et il faut vraiment prendre acte
du fait de de de ce qui s'est passé en
2022 2023 en Iran c'est-à-dire que alors
que le balucchistan et le Kurdistan qui
étaient les deux poumons de la révolte
sont des provinces où il y a un un
énorme accès aux armes des provinces
transfrontalières avec le Pakistan et
l'Afghanistan d'un côté avec le
Kurdistan iraakien de l'autre donc
vraiment avec des des armes qui vont qui
viennent or la résistance ne s'est pas
armé la révolte populaire après la mort
de mnamini c'est a pas tourné à une et
moi je pense qu'il faut positivement en
fait réfléchir sur ce qui s'est passé là
ou ce qui ne s'est pas passé c'està dire
que ça aurait pu être le cas et ça ne
s'est pas passé donc là il y a une
discipline et et il faut voir en fait
comment est-ce que ce ce cette peur
cette ce spectre de la guerre de
l'armement du conflit et de la joue en
fait pour étouffer la révolte je vous
donne par juste après on parle en détail
du hzbolah allez-y oui je dis vous posez
la question de savoir si cette crise du
palestinien pouvait souder les gens en
Iran c'est le contraire en dem après la
guerre de 2006 les Iraniens ont dit
l'Iran avant le Liban et donc les
Iraniens sont très opposés massivement
même dans les milieux islamiques en
disant on a des problèmes économiques en
Iran et ont donné 1 million 10000
dollars à chaque palestinien qui a perdu
sa maison et les gens ét sans logement à
téran deuxième chose importante qu'on
voit ces jour-ci le gouvernement irnien
n'arrête pas de dire les différents
proxis sont autonomes donc les proxis
sont les sont les ministes en question
les Alliés estce c'est le cas parce que
là vous nous dites il les arment il les
finance il les équipent est-ce qu'il
est-ce que T peut appuyer sur un bouton
et les autres agissent ou c'est pas
comme ça il y a une marge d'autonomie y
a une marge d'automie le hbollah surtout
est un parti libanais alors dit pas trop
parce qu'on va en parler donc
concrètement les Iraniens savent aussi
pour revenant à l'intérieur ils savent
très bien que ça peut être du contraire
c'est une guerre extérieure si l'Iran é
impliqué en tant que nation les
Américains bombardent un petit peu et
cetera ça peut au contraire être un peu
ce qui s'est passé à l'Argentine ou ou
en Turquie pour faire tomber le régime
des militaires la guerre extérieure des
Malouines de Chypre a cristallisé les
oppositions et en irant les oppositions
intérieures on l'a vu avec massamini ça
existe et donc le gouvernement iranien a
pour job de sauver la République
islamique aujourd'hui c'est ça son
problème c'est pas la Palestine et c'est
très bien entré dans une guerre qu'il ne
peut plus contrôler parce qu'il est
faible hein et il il a une peur bleue
que ça éclate ouais alors c'est relais
justement c'est proxy le terme que vous
employez les les les uns et les autres
ils sont ciblés tiens notamment par le
ministre britannique des Affaires
étrangèr quand ils mettent en garde la
République islamique on
l'écoute nous avons clairement indiqué à
l'Iran qu'il serait tout à fait
contraire à ses intérêts de voir la
situation s'envenimer nous ne voulons
pas que les milices ou les organisations
terroristes qu'il financent comme nous
le savons soit impliqué dans cette
affaire nous devons éviter l'escalade
nous devons acheminer l'aide humanitaire
à la population de Gaza et nous devons
veiller à ce que cette situation
terrible terrible ne s'aggrave pas pour
les habitants de la
région et donc on on parle du Hezbollah
libanais avec vous Steve Jourdain
l'attitudeb scruté de près de très près
oui est-on en train d'assister à une
escalade à la frontière entre Israël et
le Liban tout dépend du sens qu'on met
derrière ce mot escalade en temps normal
les événements de ces derniers jours de
ces dernières heures aurait presque
certainement déclenché une guerre entre
Israël et le hzbollah à la frontière les
affrontements sont quasi quotidiens hier
six roquettes ont été tirées depuis le
Liban vers le nord d'Israël unee d'entre
ell a frappé un immeuble de la ville de
kiryatchma c'est une localité de 20000
habitants situé à 2 km seulement de la
frontière la ville avait été évacuée
quelques jours auparavant par les
autorités israéliennes donc pas de
victime à déplorer mais on est
clairement dans une montée de tension he
de part et d'autre vous en parliz tout à
l'heure Thomas le hzbola tente et bien
d'harceler l'armée israélienne pour la
freiner dans ses opérations à Gaza le
Premier ministre libanais s'est exprimé
à ce sujet aujourd'hui
[Musique]
écoutez-le je constate que l'escalade ne
touche pas seulement le Liban je crains
qu'elle ne s'étend dans toute la région
plongeant le Moyen-Orient dans le
chaos jusqu'à présent le Hezbollah gère
ses questions avec rationalité et
sagesse mais je ne peux pas rassurer les
Libanais sur quoi que ce soit car les
choses sont soumise à leur
timing que cherche le hbola dans ces
affrontements on en SAA plus vendredi
Thas vendredi son chef Hassan nrala va
enfin s'exprimer publiquement première
fois depuis le début de la guerre entre
Israël et le Hamas c'est ce qu' annoncé
le sbola dans un communiqué une vidéo un
peu énigmatique a aussi été publiée hier
on va le voir on est un peu entre
Hitchcock et Star Wars vous voyez Assan
nasrala qui passe devant le drapeau bien
du du mouvement du hzbola son discours à
venir sera nous ditons consacré au
martyres qui sont morts pour Jérusalem
la semaine dernière le hzbollah a publié
une liste de ses combattants morts dans
les échanges de avec l'armée israélienne
il y en aurait aujourd'hui plus d'une
cinquantaine ça commence à faire
beaucoup ouais et le hzbollah se dit
prêt à un conflit avec Israël oui on va
voir quelques chiffres fa les rappeler
le hzbola c'est officiellement 100000
hommes en armes ils n'ont pas d'avion de
comin ni de tank mais disposeraiit de
150000 roquettes et missiles selon les
experts et bien on parle de
l'organisation nonétatique la mieux
dotée en armes au monde le hbola serait
aujourd'hui capable de tirer plusieurs
milliers de requettes par jour sur
Israël à titre de comparaison lors de la
dernière guerre du Liban en 2006 il n'en
tirait que entre guillemets quelques
centaines au quotidien à l'époque le
hzbolah était entré en guerre contre
israëlle 18 jours après une incursion de
tsal dans la bande de Gaza la suite de
l'enlèvement du soldat Gilat Shalit en
réponse au tir de missile du Hezbollah
l'armée israélienne avait alors lancé
une grande opération au Liban le conflit
avait duré plus d'un mois et fait plus
d'une plus d'un millier de morts civiles
merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain pour ces
rappels historiques bernardard je
reviens vers vous sur vous disiez que
finalement le l'Iran avait avait un
fusil à deux coups le le Hamas le
hzbollah le hzbollah c'est l'arme la
plus forte en tout cas l'arme extérieure
la plus forte tout à fait et le hzbollah
a une expérience militaire considérable
en Syrie c'est quand même le Hesbollah
qui a combattu les iranien était là
comme conseiller mais sur le terrain
c'est le hzbollah qui était là une
longue expérience de la guerre de 2006
bref il y a une vraie armée qui a une
vraie expérience militaire et par
ailleurs le hzbollah fait partie du
gouvernement libanais c'est un état
c'est beaucoup plus solide disons une
implantation sociale très importante
donc c'est une vrai fusil mais c'est un
canon c'est pas un fusil mais ils savent
très bien aussi les gens du Sud Liban le
sud Liban était ravagé après la guerre
de 2006 et donc ils savent très bien
comme justement le Liban le hzbollah
c'est une organisation sociale qui se
soucie des gens qui ont été martyrisé en
2006 ils n'ont pas envie de recommencer
le prix exorbitant et le hzbollah
risquit de perdre son assis politique au
Liban si jamais il y avait une guerre
parce que le hzbollah va parayer Israël
de la carte dans la fin de la bataille
c'est Israël qui va gagner h et LEB qui
va perdre et qui a perdu donc son moyen
de pression sur Israël qui n'est pas
mortel mais qui peut faire mal donc tout
est rationnel et en principe il n'y aura
pas d'incidence sauf de quelques
bombardements d'ici et là sauf ou mais
quand on entendeit Steve journal en dans
d'autres circonstances les les les les
bombardements auraiit provoqué une une
réaction militaire d'ra mais aujourd'hui
on sait très bien que les Américains
sont là que le nucléaire iranien est
derrière le rideau aussi que on va quand
même vers les Américains ne sont ne sont
plus dans la région ils sont en Chine
aujourd'hui hein il il il y a plus
personne sur place et il y a une
organisation régionale qui se met en
place euh dans la l'émission précédente
que vous aviez vous avez analysé les
votes à l'onuou dans les votes à l'ONU
l'Europe est divisée le monde est divisé
et le Grand Sud comme on dit le sud
nouveau apparît l'Iran et l'Arabie
Saoudite et dans sont dans les bricks
avec la Chine la Russie l'Afrique du Sud
et cetera ils y rentreront l' entreront
mais faut dire que désormais la carte
n'est pas dans les mains des grandes
puissances on a plus les moyens par
contre les pays de la région doivent se
débrouiller et c'est ça qui est nouveau
dans cette on sait pas ce qui va s'en
sortir mais une chose est certaine c'est
ni les Français ni les américains ni les
Russes ni peut-être même les chinois
sont peut-être de loin ne vont trouver
des solution la la guerre est que la
solution viendra des pays de des pays de
la région alors lesquels les anciens la
Jordanie s'est usé le Liban n'existe pas
l'Égypte est fatigué mais l'Arabie
saoudite a de l'argent prestige
religieux proaméricain et il voudrait et
les Iraniens le savent se réunir trouver
des solutions avec Israël accord
d'Abraham compte et les Iraniens savent
très bien que si c'est pas aujourd'hui
c'est de demain que l'Arabie Saoudite et
Israël seront seront proches donc il
faut réétablir les choses et l'Iran veut
garder ses moyens je je reviens au
hbollah et je me tourne vers vous dphine
Minoui un peu la même question que
Mathieu proposait proposé tout à l'heure
concernant le le Hamas le degré
d'autonomie du hzbollah par rapport à
l'Iran aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on peut
en dire d'après vous
oui c'est vrai que le Hezbollah reste
l'enfant de la République islamique mais
il y a en effet un degré
d'autonomie on sent qu'on est quand même
dans la R tenu en ce moment du côté du
hzbollah il y a tous les jours des des
affrontements à la frontière il y a des
des villages du sud Liban qui ont été
évacué on parle de 30000 personnes qui
auraient quitté le sud Liban à ce jour
en 3 semaines de de de conflit il y
aurait entre 50 et 60 personnes qui
auraient été tué dont un journaliste de
l'agence
Reuters mais pour l'instant au-delà même
des des menaces verbal proféré par
l'Iran on sent que le
Hezbollah reste dans la retenue et G de
ces options ouvertes j'imagine aussi en
fonction de de l'offensive israélienne
là on en est au tout début de
l'offensive terrestre c'est un peu la
deuxième phase du conflit si l'offensive
est accentuée si les
opérations sont accélérées c'est
peut-être là en effet à un moment où le
hzbollah se devra d'agir has votre avis
là-dessus sur cette engrenage là est-ce
qu'il est déjà enclenché et est-ce qu'on
peut l'arrêter d'une certaine façon
d'abord sur le sur les solutions moi je
ne crois pas du tout à un rôle exercé
par l'Arabie Saoudite qui aujourd'hui
marque une absence mais flagrante on le
voit bien aujourd'hui l'Arabie Saoudite
elle prépare le premier championnat le
prochain Championnat du Monde jeu
électronique il y a le festival de de
Riad d'ailleurs il sont dans le soft
power absolument non l'Arabie Saoudite
ne veut pas d'ailleurs et elle est dans
une position très délicate parce qu' un
engagement évidemment dans un sens ou
dans un autre risque finalement de
porter préjudice à la fois aux efforts
de Mohamed Ben Salman de renouer avec
Isra d'accord a Bern parce que ils ont
laissé passer le message que les accords
d'Abraham étaient pas abandonnés et que
il faudrait les les
réenclencher ils étaient en train ils
étaient en train je me suis mal exprimé
mais ils étaient le processus de
rapprochement é était enclenché oui il a
dit avant le avant avant il faudra
reprendre les discussions et il a quand
même dit il faudra reprendre les
discussions là où étaient voilà mais ça
reste de la rhtorique ça c'est en terme
d'action malheureusement on voit pas
leat par c'est trop tôt non oui c'est
trop tôt mais parce que c'est une
position qui est délicate pour Mohamed
Ben Salman il est pressé pour prendre le
pouvoir il sait que les Iraniens sont là
et sont forts il veut pas risquer la
normalisation avec Teran et non plus sa
relation un petit peu difficile avec les
États-Unis il y a je ne vois pas
vraiment d'État dans la région en mesure
si l'Europe elle-même n'arrive pas à
jouer un quelconque rôle comment
voulez-vous que les États du
Moyen-Orient l'Égypte la Jordanie lié à
une aide importante entre 800 million et
un milliard pour en jouer un rôle moi je
dirais que les États-Unis le seul pays
qui a déplacé de nav dire en quelques
heures c'est bien les États-Unis et ça
c'est important malheureusement il y a
une question militaire je termine vous ê
pas d'accord làus vous pourrez répondre
allez-y TER je termine par votre
question sur sur le Hezbollah moi je
pense que c'est le Hezbollah est le vrai
indicateur de l'engagement iranien ou
non c'est pas le Hamas le Hamas d'abord
il a un pragmatisme de par et d'autres
souvenez-vous le printemps arabe les
Syriens se révolent contre bacharassad
le Hamas dans qui est quand même issu du
Frère Musulman prend ses distances avec
le régime de Bachar alors qu'ils avaient
des bureaux il se retirent de Damas
iranien le premier soutien avec les
Russes du régime de bacharassad on dit
Hamas il y a aucun problème on comprend
votre opposition notre alliance elle
reste elle-même donc il y a un
progmatisme le seul pragmatisme le seul
c'est hizbah hizbah cert on l'a dit avec
l'Iran et il y a moins d'autonomie c'est
ce que vous nous dites non le Hamas a
plus d'autonomie a plus d'autonomie que
lezbollah lezbollah certes il ob un
agenda électoral bernardade l'a rappelé
c'est il veut absolument rester dans le
pouvoir il il participe dans la prise de
décision ça il a acquis une expertise il
a acquis vous savez quand vous avez des
ministres députés qui deviennent des
ministres ça veut dire vous faites vous
tournez votre élite et elle devient
partie prenante dans la prise de
décision en revanche si les Iraniens
évidemment veulent veulent l'embrasement
ou veulent ouvrir le franc Nord le
hzbollah ne peut pas dire non non j'ai
des intérêts électoruxx un mot de
réponse sur l'Arabie Saoudite je voyez
les Iraniens sont fous mais ils sont pas
idiots ils savent très bien que si ça
s'embrasse il ne contrôle pas sur
l'Arabie Saoudite les deux pays Iran et
Arabie Saoudite sont les deux futures
grandes puissances de la région en
économie en société avec toutes les
réformes qui sont à faire et pour
l'Arabie Saoudite l'accord avec Israël
aujourd'hui ou demain est nécessaire
pour apaiser la région ils savent que le
problème palestinien est une difficulté
comme le Yémen par exemple ou comme
l'Afghanistan et cetera donc ils ont
intérêt à faire ça et les les drames de
ces jours-ci ont montré que la question
palestinienne devrait être prise en
compte don l'Arabie Saoudite n pas envie
elle n jamais rien fait mais est obligé
aujourd'hui de s'impliquer si sinon
l'accord d'abrah ne pourra pas se faire
elle a intérêt à le faire et cetera et
donc je pense que il y a là des choses
qui peuvent se mettre en place mais ça
demandera du temps parce qu'ave les
drames de C temps-ci personne n'est prêt
à discuter bien évidemment on sera tous
morts espérons que espér espérons que
non le pire n'est jamais sûr je voudrais
justement je voudrais parler du du de du
nucléaire du programme militaire
nucléaire iranien comment il comment
c'est instrumentalisé justement par par
par le régime des Mola aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'ils en parlent beaucoup alors
dans dans dans les médias iraniens oui
ça bien sûr ça a sa place mais la façon
dont ça a été instrumentalisé c'était
bien sûr pour euh chercher une espèce de
soutien de la communauté internationale
la République islamique a reçu un
soutien en fait de la de la communauté
internationale à partir de janvier 2023
avec des négociations qui sont qui ont
repris et une espèce de normalisation
euh à travers voilà aussi à partir du de
de de ces négociation autour d'
nucléaire et euh ce ce soutien là cette
trahison en fait de la part de la
communauté internationale de la rue
iranienne puisque la communauté
internationale s'est assis sur les
acquis de la rue qui avait déstabilisé
le régime qui avait euh fragilisé le
régime pour venir négocier avec ce
régime qui ne négocie que quand il est
en situation de de de faiblesse et donc
du coup lui permettre de reprendre du
poil de la bê donc un ressentiment de de
parti des Iraniens vis-à-is de la
communauté internation analogue en fait
à euh à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
et et à la grande honte en fait à la à à
la grande dévalorisation de la
communauté internationale dans son
soutien euh à à à l'État d'Israël et
dans son refus de condamner de faire
cesser les crimes de guerre de l'État
israélien à Gaza et donc en fait on a
des peuples dans la région parce que
vous parlez vous parlez d'état depuis
tout à l'heure en disant à un moment
même tout est rationnel enfin bon des
bombardements sans cesse sur 2 millions
de personnes depuis 20 jours avec au
moins 8000 morts pour moi ce n'est pas
rationnel donc en fait on a des peuples
dans la région qui à chaque fois sont
pris en otage d'une espèce de Réal
politique dont le cinisme est tellement
tourne tellement à avec par exemple
l'Iran au Conseil des droits de l'homme
de l'ONU de l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU avec la Syrie qui a été normalisé
à nouveau et cetera et cetera que en
fait il faut aussi prendre prendre acte
de la puissance que peut avoir en terme
de révolte sachant que la société
libanaise s'est révoltée en 2020 la
société irakienne s'est révoltée
notamment contre l'influence de l'Iran
et la façon dont l'Iran sucè tous les
toute l'économie de l'Irak et donc en
fait on a aussi c ces espèces de de de
marmite en en ébullition de d'absence de
boussole morale de communauté
internationale qui a perdu en fait tout
crédit et on ne sait pas ce que ces
situations là vont pouvoir amener avec
ces populations avec lesquelles il faut
compter en fait oui c'est vrai que c'est
c'est dans l'équation parce que par
exemple dans la réaction de l'Arabie
Saoudite ou d'autres pays puissants de
la région il y a il y a le le poids de
l'opinion même si ce sont pas des
démocraties mais la la mobilisation
propalestinienne c'est un facteur à
intégrer ça direct intégré il ne
mobilise pas tout le monde comme on
vrait le croire les régimes n'ont pas
intention à à développer le sentiment
propalestinien parce que ça ne marche
pas mais ce que dit ch maaremi est
important les populations jouent du rôle
depuis 30 ans que ce soit en Algérie que
ce soit les printemps arabes que ce soit
en Iran et les gouvernements même les
plus despotiques sont obligés de tenir
compte de cela c'est pour ça que je
crois que étant donné grande puissance
non plus la puivoire qu'ils avaient
avant malgré leurs deux porte-avion les
Américains qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire
envoyer tro qu missiles sur l'Iran ils
vont pas envahir le Liban ni quoi que ce
soit
donc la paralysie des grandes puissances
est évidente donc c'est du wish thinking
mais de dire bon qu'est-ce qu'il y a
dans tout cette situation irrationnelle
et absurde et dramatique est-ce qu'il y
a quelques rapport de force qui pourrai
être avancé et donc je P effectivement
on est actuellement avec l'émergence des
pays qu'on disait jadis tirmonde qui
sont aujourd'hui de nouveaux pays qui
émergent qui ne sont pas les uniquement
la Chine et l'Inde mais aussi l'Afrique
du Sud tous ces pays-là ils se rendent
compte qu'ils n'ont pas le choix les
grandes puissances sont incapables de
les aider il les ont pas aidé pendant 50
ans c'est c'est fini il faut qu'il se
retrouve sur les manches avec 1000
difficultés des millions de difficultés
mais le débat est là et je crois que
c'est ça qui est important et la crise
du de la Palestine parce qu'elle est
très symbolique et très dramatique et
peut-être un des ingrédients avec une
catastrophe énorme qui permettra de dire
bon arrêtons il faut vraiment qu'on
trouve une solution merci les Américains
et les Russes et les chinois mais on se
débrouille tout seul je veux juste
rajouter un petit élément quand je parle
avec mes collègues israéliens on parle
de la des accords d'Abraham je leur dis
vous savez on a déjà fait la paix avec
l'Égypte et la Jordanie h finalement
c'est une paix au niveau des régimes
politiques elle n'est pas traduite c'est
très difficile pour un Israélien d'aller
dans le quartier le plus populaire du
CER ou d'aller en Jordanie maises
collègues ils me disent mais nous oui on
est conscient mais en fait cette paix
c'est vrai que c'est pas une paix
populaire embrassée par la population
qui reste acquise à la cause
palestinienne à la question des droit
mais pour nous en fait il suffit de ne
pas faire la guerre nous savons que
c'est des régimes politiques qui sont
dispotiques autoritair
mais ne pas faire la guerre pour nous
c'est déjà les accords d'Abraham c'est
déjà la paix mais c'est insuffisant
parce que je leur dit pourquoi aller
chercher la paix avec le Maroc qui ne
partage pas de de frontière avec Israël
alors qu'on devrait parf faire la paix
avec vos voisins palestiniens il disent
nous c'est moi d'viter à ce que des
États arabes soient en conflit avec
nousou alors j'aime pas inutilement
remuer les peurs il y a suffisamment
d'acteurs dans tous les pays qui le font
mais quand même je je je reprends la
question sur le nucléaire iranien
Bernard sont-ils de leur programme
militaire est-ce que c'est une menace
potentielle on sa très bien grâce à
Monsieur Trump dans le programme le
contrôle du programme a été arrêté les
Iraniens ont repris leur program comme
ils ont voulu ils sont très compétents
scientifiquement et aujourd'hui ils ont
la capacité de faire une arme atomique
le jour où ils le voudront ça prendra 3
mois 6 mois 2 ans je nen sait rien mais
l'Iran est arrivé à ce niveau-là et
l'Arabie Saoudite le sait ça c'est
irréversible le chat revient au pouvoir
demain matin le nucléaire iranien reste
là aujourd'hui finalement l'Arabie
Saoudite sait très bien que si l'Iranien
ont une arme eux aussi l'auront et les
les Iraniens sont d'accord on s'entend
on est on est deux pays comme les Russes
américains avaient des bombes on en aura
aussi donc il y a plus de pression sur
le nucléaire qui n'est plus une question
centrale la seule question pour l'Iran
sont les sanctions économiques qui
effectivement brisent complètement
l'État mais surtout la société iranienne
qui est paralysé et n'a plus la
dynamique que l'on lu connaissait alors
vous parliez de la de la la situation de
la société iranienne cette révolte qui
dure depuis plus d'un an depuis
septembre je vous propose de regarder un
un visage qui symbolise finalement ce
combat qui continue pour la jeunesse du
du pays elle s'appelait armita garavand
licène de 16 ans agressée dans le métro
de Tan pour ne pas avoir porté le
foulard islamique après un mois de de
coma son décès a été annoncé c'était ce
samedi samedi dernier par une agence de
presse officielle euh ch maarimi est-ce
que ce sa mort peut raviver euh la la
flamme des manifestations en Iran armita
Garavan était CDE iranien hein comme
Marsa Jina Amini donc ça c'est encore
une fois ouais
euh euh il y a eu des il y a eu des euh
des des slogans qui ont été chantés sur
les toits il y a pas eu de manifestation
euh euh suite à à la mort de d'armita il
y a euh plusieurs dizaines en fait de de
militantes qui ont participé à son
enterrement euh sa famille souhaitait
l'enterrer près de carmananscha là où
elle est d'où elle est originaire l'État
n'a pas voulu elle a été enterrée à à
théran euh la la militante et avocate
Nasrine sotoué a été arrêté à son
enterrement à l'interrement d'armita
parce qu'elle ne portait pas de voile
arrêté pour cause de euh atteinte à la
sécurité psychologique de de la société
et et donc elle Estelle elle est
désormais en prison et elle entamaé une
greffe de la fin euh en fait c'est un ça
je ne pense pas que ça ravive les
insurrections le mouvement
insurrectionnel mais par contre ça se
place dans cette continuité longue euh
des formes de résistance quelque chose a
bougé profondou ça s'est jamais arrêté
la résistance continue elle elle a pris
d'autres formes les liges ont bougé les
lignes ont bougé les valeurs ont bougé
les affectes ont bougé la la la la
l'identification nationale des Iraniens
a bougé et en fait on est dans cette
dansm dans cette phase là et c'est une
phase aussi de résistance civile c'est
une phase je pense où les Iraniens vont
utiliser les acquis qu'ils ont eu durant
toute la période réformiste de façon de
savoir en fait être en en guerre de
guérri à civile avec l'état de façon
absolument non violente et et
quotidienne mais juste en dessous du
seuil où la répression pourrait être
trop trop intense et ils vont utiliser
ces acquis là non pas pour demander des
réformes mais pour demander le
changement qu'il souhaite maintenant et
c'est clair pour tout le monde tout le
monde souhaite le le changement en Iran
eu est-ce que dans on a commencé à le
dire au début dans dans la relative
prudence euh de du du pouvoir iranien
aujourd'hui il y a pas cette crainte
finalement qu'un conflit qui se
généraliserait qui qui frapperait
directement l'Iran puisse bah donner le
l'opportunité à la rue de se réveiller
et de faire tomber le régime des Molin
j'ai lu dans certains médias il parlait
un petit peu de le fils rizab balawii je
crois qui est allé en Israël et d'autres
opposants pour dire voilà les traîtres
de la nation ou qui ont souten bien dans
le combat par contreez le régim iranien
il reste fè ça c'est le réflexe
patriotique dont on parlait tout à
l'heure fidèle fidèle à ces principes je
pense que le régime iranien a encore des
ressources intérieur pour hélas encore
renforcer ces pratiques autoritaires et
d'ailleurs cette prudence elle explique
finalement les priorités du régime
iranien c'est-à-dire que d'accord pour
soutenir ces relais à l'étranger mais
essayons essayons de ne pas finalement
simisser dans le conflit maintenant à
Gaza et d'ailleurs le dernier
porte-parole du Hamas est très
intéressant certains des région de Hames
il commence à dire il est où l'Iran il
est où le Hezbollah vous avez bien dit
qu'en cas
d'incursion terrestre vous allez bouger
pour pour nous soutenir et donc ça fait
un débat très intéressant dans le monde
arabe pour dire finalement les Iraniens
ont vendu la cause et certains saouiens
disent on vous a bien dit que le conflit
de Hamas est un conflit plutôt au
service des Iraniens qui vous ont lâché
allez il nous reste 30 secondes Bernard
même même question sur le le la prudence
du régime avec le risque de la rue oui
je crois que les événements de Massa
mini ont montré que il y avit des choses
très fragiles en Iran et le régime a eu
peur oui il a contrôlé le système il
sait très bien que ça peut éclater chez
les enseignants chez les ouvriers chez
les paysans n'importe où ils savent que
l'ffervescence c'est partout il y a une
grande victoire avec massamini désormais
une femme dans un quartier de porte plus
le foulard elles se font arrêter quelque
fois mais globalement c'est une victoire
et ça pourrait être une victoire aussi
dans d'autres eur et la crise
palestinienne pourrait être un
catalyseur peut-être de différentes
crises et c'est ça que CRA le régime
iranien actuellement merci beaucoup je
vais rapidement citer vos livres femme
vie liberté aux éditions La Découverte
Bernard Ourcade Iran paradoxe d'une
nation c'était aux éditions du
cnrsabidi le MoyenOrient selon Joe Biden
livre collectif aux éditions Éric Bonier
et Delphine Minoui je ne vous oublie pas
et je vous remercie encore une fois
d'avoir participé à notre débat je vous
écris de Tran au point merci à toutes et
à tous de votre fidè
à ce sens public je vous donne
rendez-vous demain 18h22h et puis notez
que Fabiane Keller la députée européenne
Renaissance sera l'invité de la matinale
et Dorian mansini bonne
soirée